mother nature is going to give away
another really nice day today you guys
slightly warmer though by the afternoon
yesterday we just made it to 89 degrees
looking out over the north valley right
now temperatures a mix of 60s and 70s
around the valley it is really a nice
morning temperatures pretty close to
normal a little under a little above we
have kind of a mix of all of that out
there winds on the light side nellis
you've been bumping around a little bit
with those winds and we've had some
breezes in other spots right now
mesquite's pretty quiet at 66. indian
springs in the 50s mid 60s for prompt 81
still in laughlin 57 in kingman a little
breeze along the colorado river valley
this morning and in the upper 80s in
death valley 50 in tonopah 33
in ely and 44 in caliani this morning
we're looking for a high perfectly
normal today at 92 we thought we'd make
it into the low 90s yesterday we just
didn't quite make it 89 but that's all
right another day in the 80s we'll take
it don't get too many of those in may
seems like we want to heat up in a hurry
in the month of may 92 perfectly normal
105 is the
the record high sunset will be 7 47 this
evening days are getting naturally
longer now as we have just about a month
left of spring
a little less than a month just barely
lots of spring thunderstorms and showers
across the middle parts of the country
the plains and then some flooding rains
across the carolinas yesterday but also
some of these thunderstorms have
produced some very vivid lightning along
with some heavy rain and hail we'll go
all the way down to the southern tip of
texas this is harlingen
and this was caught on camera by derrick
garcia oh my gosh what a lightning show
we used to get storms like this all the
time in the desert especially during
monsoon season where that lightning just
lasts and lights up the sky
we'll see monsoon seasons around the
corner for us coming in july so we'll
see if we get some of those good
thunderstorms but man that rain has been
very intense and heavy across southern
texas harlingen is just north of
brownsville just right across from the
mexico border there in the very southern
tip of the lone star state west west
u.s western u.s under high pressure but
there is still some snow in central
colorado this morning enjoy the sun just
make sure you're staying hydrated
because those northeasterly breezes
dried us out even more yesterday we've
got as little as 10 percent humidity
this morning won't get much wind today
just a little more heat and then a lot
more heat at the end of the week look at
that 102 on thursday our hottest day but
as we roll into the holiday weekend we
get breezy winds a few clouds around on
saturday and then a cool down
back to the low 90s for memorial day
monday that'll be very pleasant a lot of
people will be outdoors
going to the veterans memorial cemetery
in boulder city i'm sure so i like it
when it cools off a little bit for
memorial day oh for sure